alkoholkonsum ohne reue beziehungsweise
ohne kopfschmerzen sehen auf dem mars
das sind drei der fünf themen heute in
den klick zum top news dranbleiben rund
4000 tote innerhalb von 24 stunden grund
die luftverschmutzung aufgrund dieser
sterben in china tatsächlich alle 24
stunden so viele menschen und wie viele
sterben durch innere verschmutzung im
jahr 2030 würden einer studie zufolge
zwei millionen chinesen sterben warum
weil sie zu viel rauchen obwohl in
vielen ländern die raucherinnen und
raucher weniger werden stirbt der
weltgesundheitsorganisation nach jeder
zweite raucher an seinem genuss in china
sterben millionen daran und es wird wohl
auch noch viel mehr zitat etwa zwei
drittel der jungen chinesischen männer
werden zurück zigarettenraucher und die
meisten beginnen damit bevor sie 20
jahre alt sind so berichten die forscher
in ihrer jetzt im fachmagazin lancet
veröffentlichten studie im jahr 2050
würden sogar drei millionen chinesen an
ihrem tabakkonsums sterben auf dieses
erschreckende resultat kamen die
wissenschaftler indem sie zwei
langzeiterhebung aus china analysierten
kann das überhaupt noch irgendwie
gestoppt werden
ja sagen die forscher dafür müssten
einfach die chinesen aufhören zu rauchen
und selbst dann würde es bis zu zehn
jahre dauern bis sich die lage entspannt
der grund sind die langzeitfolgen des
rauchens her in europa da wird es ja
langsam weniger und die todeszahlen
sinken langsam hoffen wir dass das auch
mal in china der frei sein wird
wir kommen aus der berichterstattung rum
dabei dem mars nicht mehr heraus es ist
gerade mal eine woche her dass
rückstände von wasser auf dem mars
gefunden wurden und jetzt jetzt hat das
team der nasa-sonde curiosity ganze
sehen gefunden in den seen gibt es zwar
kein wasser mehr aber dass es sehen
waren gilt als sicher vor rund drei
milliarden jahren hatten diese sogar
rund 10.000 jahre auf dem mars
überdauert dieser fund könnte die these
dass es früher einmal leben auf dem mars
gegeben hat bekräftigen curiosity ist
ein rover der seit drei jahren
die karge landschaft des mars untersucht
bilder die dieser rover geschossen hatte
zeigen den forschern große spuren die
von den seen beziehungsweise von dem
wasser dieser sehen stammen könnte es
bleibt also spannend wir erfahren nach
und nach immer mehr über den
erdähnlichen planeten also bleibt dran
aber bleibt auch in diesem video dran es
geht weiter die aussage eines
australischen wodka hersteller das zitat
natürlich heißen wir übermäßigen
alkoholkonsum nicht gut na ja etwas
kurios dieses zitat betrachtet man deren
neueste errungenschaft sie haben ein
wodka zusammengestellt der keinerlei
negative nachwirkungen am nächsten
morgen bereiten soll
wie mit dem vitamin b c und kann diese
würden mitunter die entwässerung des
körpers durch den alkohol herabsetzen um
alkohol chemisch abzubauen benötigt der
körper nimmt jede menge wasser zitat die
basis aus zucker ruhe die wir verwenden
hilft dabei die langsame vitamin
freisetzung beizubehalten die wiederum
den alkohol kompensiert der die vitamin
aufnahme beeinflusst so bradley mitten
einer der hersteller david thompson und
bradley mitten von der firma vitamin
alkohol company will einen solchen wodka
auf den markt bringen zu funktionieren
scheint es zitat in all unseren
unabhängigen test zeigte sich dass nur
wenige personen einen kater hatten
nachdem sie nur vitamin wodka also so
heißt er und keinen anderen alkohol
konsumiert hatten so die hersteller
die tonnenschweren säugetiere die
elefanten haben gelernt mit krebstumoren
umzugehen so ganz einfach ist es nicht
aber sie können es und zwar haben
wissenschaftler des hans man's renner
instituts in salt lake city folgendes
herausgefunden elefanten besitzen 38
mehr gehen kopien des eiweißes p53
dieses eiweiß wird auch als
tumorsuppressor bezeichnet also als
tumor unterdrücker diese haben zwar auch
wir menschen allerdings macht der nicht
wirklich seine arbeit und 40 stück davon
haben wir erst recht nicht wir haben
gerade mal zwei davon bei den elefanten
aktiviert dieser unterdrücker bei den
krebs befallenen und beschädigten zellen
den selbstzerstörungs modus sie können
sich also schlagartig nicht mehr
vermehren und sie dezimieren sich
langsam wird es schon bald die pille für
den mann geben japanischen
wissenschaftlern der universität von
osaka ist alle womöglich für die zukunft
bedeutende entdeckung im bereich der
verhütungsmittel gelungen sie haben
geschafft spermien mit hilfe von pillen
also medikamenten so unfähig zu machen
dass sie nicht in die eizelle eindringen
konnten spermien müssen ja einen langen
weg dorthin zurück legen auf dem weg
dorthin verirren sich einige oder sind
einfach zu schwach
das spermium das in die eizelle
eindringen will erwartet einen dann ein
noch härterer job und dafür brauchen die
spermien jede menge kraft und für diese
kraft brauchen sie das eiweiß kalzium
bzw eine form der form des karzinoms p p
p 3c dieses eiweiß ist für die spermien
ausschlaggebend damit sie das ziel
erreichen können also in die eizelle
einzudringen mit einem p p p 3c blogger
konnten die forscher spermien vom
männlichen mäusen derartig schwächen
dass sie unfruchtbar würden also nicht
mehr in die zelle eindringen konnten
vier bis fünf tage nach der einnahme der
medikamente hat die wirkung eingesetzt
darüber berichteten sie im fachmagazin
science nachdem die mäuse keine blogger
mehr bekommen hatten waren sich schon
innerhalb der nächsten woche wieder
fruchtbar funktioniert also ganz
as tisch wie sich die medikamente auf
den menschen auswirken das ist noch
nicht bekannt aber die forscher gehen
davon aus dass die p p p p 3c blogger
genauso auch beim menschen funktionieren
das war wirklich sensationell wenn wir
empfängnisverhütung könnten ohne frauen
hormone zu geben wir sind also gespannt
wie die weiteren tests verlaufen
vielleicht gibt es also demnächst die
pille für den mann
die viagra pille für den mann die gibt
es ja schon lange für die frauen soll es
so eine ähnliche pille in zukunft auch
geben also die macht natürlich nicht
steigert die lust mehr dazu erfahrt ihr
hier oben und ami zu rap und zum block
kommt ihr auch untergrund diskutiert
doch mal in den kommentaren über die
pille für den mann glaubt er dass sich
die durchsetzen könnte könnte oder eher
nicht wie seht ihr das
also bis dann bleibt dran